- South Carolina Sheriff's deputies are  on paid leave after two women died in a  flooded van the deputies were driving  Nicolette green and Wendy Newton were  being transported to mental health  facilities when floodwaters overtook the  van Tuesday night in South Carolina law  enforcement officials are responsible  for taking people to facilities where  they are being involuntarily committed  the Horry County sheriff said the  deputies tried to free the women but  could not get them out of the back of  the van he said there's no sign that the  women were in any restraints the  deputies were rescued from the roof of  the vehicle the sheriff said it appears  they drove around a barrier blocking the  road this investigation is still  underway there are a lot of unanswered  questions at that story right